mayor of new york has in
the city of new york as a new mayor his
name is eric adams former subway cops
seems like it could be a big improvement
over bill de plazio unfortunately he has
continued
bill de blasio's state of emergency
based on covet he's also continued the
vaccine mandate for indoor venues which
is insane
so a lot of new yorkers are continuing
to flee to florida and that would
include new york congress person sandy
cortez who the national media persisted
calling aoc as if it's their job to make
her myth let her do it herself her
name's not aoc it's sandy that's what
they called her
anyway sandy went to florida on vacation
with her boyfriend and of course she
didn't wear a mask she got caught on
video not wearing a mask and got
attacked her defense i'm a very sexy
lady
quote if republicans are mad that they
can't date me they can just say that
instead of projecting their sexual
frustrations onto my boyfriend's feet
you creepy weirdo
who's that creepy weirdo sandy anyway
candace owens is the host of candace she
joins us to figure out who the creepy
weirdo is here candace great to see you
what what do you make of her i'm just
too sexy like you can't criticize me
does that work
listen i saw this and i actually
couldn't believe my eyes and i tried to
create a sober analysis of what made her
tweet that and by the way it got worse
she had a second tweet that said there
are sexual frustrations that underpin
republicans critiques of me their
fixation on me so she's really actually
creating a sexual narrative and in my
sober analysis i believe that she wasn't
sober i think you know alcohol loosens
your inhibitions and i think that she
was about 10 margaritas deep in miami
enjoying the free state of florida and
she wrote something that was honestly
just filth i mean how bizarre and
immature is it for any person any person
that wants to be taken seriously as an
adult to look at a fair critique of them
as an elected official who has been
barking about how florida is doing
everything wrong about how bad ronda
stanton is to see this critique and to
offer back well you know what you just
want to sleep with me i mean what are we
even talking about imagine if any male
did this an elected official imagine if
rand paul you know gets a critique or or
if any other person even joe biden if
joe biden was critiquing they said sir
how can you say this about climate
change and his response was well you
just want to sleep with me i mean it's
so bratty and it's so immature and it's
so disgusting to even think about and
let me just say this in case there's any
confusions i have a lot of critiques of
alexandria ocasio-cortez i've had a lot
of critique since the very beginning no
sandy i do not want to sleep with you
i think that's fair i mean it does
suggest
enormously high self-esteem bordering on
narcissism i mean if someone criticizes
you and your first thought is they just
want to have sex with me no maybe they
just don't like you that's what i always
assume when people criticize me i never
think oh well you're very attracted to
me i mean like how crazy do you have to
be i mean you're trending every other
week
you're trying yeah i don't think it's
because i'm so sexy i'm trending every
week because everybody thinks i'm sexy
and they're just venting their sexual
frustrations nobody would take you
seriously because that's simply not how
adults speak
it's the way that teenage boys who
derive sexual innuendos from everything
that's how they speak and that's where
she belongs she has the mind of a middle
schooler this is a 32 year old woman
it's really unacceptable quite frankly
and it is hilarious but it's also
unacceptable that she's actually an
elected official that sits in congress
she's an absurd person but i will say
the thing about being a 52 year old talk
show host with four kids everyone wants
you candace
it's like so insane i just love it thank
you great to see you
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else